você sabia que o seu celular que está no
seu bolso é mais potente do que o
sistema que a nasa inventou para levar o
homem até a rua
a questão é o que você sabe fazer com
toda essa tecnologia disponível e hoje
vou contar com uma programação pode
mudar o seu jeito de pensar
desde criança eu sempre fui apaixonado é
por computadores
mas eu usava ele só para passar o tempo
até que um dia o meu amigo me contou
sobre um programa para criar jogos e
esse foi o meu primeiro jogo e também
foi meu primeiro passo nesse mundo da
programação eu continuei fazendo os
projetos e em 2015
eu estava conversando com os meus amigos
ea gente descobriu que as tecnologias
disponíveis para surdos atualmente elas
são pouco acessíveis
elas são caras podem custar milhares de
reais dependendo do nível da deficiência
auditiva os surdos em o implante ou sem
o aparelho ele não consegue ouvir por
exemplo um carro buzinando e nenhum
alarme de incêndio e eu pensei será que
não dá pra gente fazer algo mais
acessível que quase todo mundo consiga
comprar e sabe quando você está num show
e tem aquelas caixas de som altíssimas
onde você consegue sentir a música
dentro do seu corpo é mais ou menos isso
que a gente pensou que teve a seguinte
ideia ao invés de fazer os surdos com
virem que vai deixar o produto caro
vamos fazer eles sentirem o som que a
gente montou uma pulseira onde ela tem
dois motores que vibram no pulso motores
do celular um lado esquerdo e um do lado
direito pra que além do surdo conseguir
sentir o som ele soubesse o volume
conforme a intensidade dessas vibrações
ea direção de onde se solta vindo por
qual o motor está vibrando mais
então por exemplo se um se um carro
passa ao lado esquerdo
a pessoa vai sentir isso isso aumenta a
sua percepção do que está acontecendo ao
seu redor é ea gente conseguiu atingir o
nosso objetivo com esse projeto porque a
gente deixou ele custando menos de 50
reais
e aí a eu pensei bom além de fazer
coisas pra mim para os meus amigos que
eram os jogos eu descobri que eu poderia
fazer algo que melhorar se a minha
cidade do meu país eu conheci várias
pessoas na internet que tinham esse
objetivo que a gente se juntou e fez
vários projetos no ano passado a gente
montou um aplicativo onde pais de
autistas conseguiu montar uma rotina com
vários exercícios do nosso aplicativo
ver o desempenho do filho como é que ele
estava progredindo e ter acesso a dicas
e esse projeto foi tão gratificante
porque ele estava alinhado o nosso
propósito ea cada projeto que você faz
no mundo da programação é uma grande
lição a gente conheceu muitas pessoas
teve que ficar lendo pesquisas e
aprendeu muita coisa mesmo
e esse projeto a gente escreveu ele em
uma competição da google e da fiap e
para nossa surpresa mesmo com o mesmo
competindo com todas as escolas do país
a gente conseguiu ficar em primeiro
lugar obrigado
é preocupante você pensar que hoje a
gente está na geração de nativos
digitais
todo mundo está conectado isso ainda não
é ensinado nas escolas e poucas pessoas
aproveitam todo esse potencial que a
tecnologia oferece hoje em dia
dependendo do que você quer fazer talvez
você não precisa escrever nenhum código
existem sites onde você consegue criar
um aplicativo só arrastando e soltando
alguns blocos o que torna a programação
muito mais fácil de aprender e desde que
eu comecei a programar o meu modo de
olhar para problemas
mudou bastante eu consigo quebrá los em
pequenas partes e às vezes pensar em
diferentes soluções algo que já existe
pode ser mais barato pode ser melhor
às vezes os dois ao mesmo tempo o que eu
quero dizer aqui é que na minha visão o
melhor meio de despertar nas crianças o
desejo de resolver os problemas que a
nossa sociedade enfrenta é ensinando
elas a programar e quando esse desejo
começa a fazer parte das nossas vidas
um ponto que a gente comece a observar
as coisas e questionar como elas
funcionam imaginar como elas poderiam
ser
é aí que surgem as soluções que ninguém
nunca antes tinha pensado
se a gente abrir as nossas mentes para o
mundo da programação a gente vai
enxergar o mundo sob uma nova
perspectiva novas possibilidades e para
vários problemas que a gente enfrenta
hoje a gente pode ter incríveis soluções
amanhã
muito obrigado